why why would morbius be in the only way i can
see morbius being intrigued is if he sincerely
meant let's do some good because that's
who orbeez's character is in this movie he
would rather do some good but if it is
a setup for the sinister six to do some
bad i'm like why would he be intrigued what's
intriguing about what he's heard so far
why is the question not what do you mean
what kind of good are you talking about
ladies and gentlemen of the reject nation
listen listen loud and clear we have no
interest in doing a morbius spoiler talk zero
they did it for us they did it all for us
before it came out but here's
what we do want to talk about
the best post-credits scenes to have ever existed
in the history of marvel that's right we just
click baited you with saying they're the worst
we're here to convince you that they're the best
ones ever played you played you idiots click
the like button and leave a comment that's
what you get for being dumb yeah anyway no these
were the worst post-credits scenes i think ever
in marvel uh since the mcu began i didn't think
anything can really top those amazing spider-man
2 ones with damn me these are magically bad they
are done themselves there's so many things and
so few things all at once real quick recap of
what happens in morbius he's a doctor with a
blood condition ends up experimenting with bats
because who wouldn't and to then find a way to
you know cure himself becomes a vampire along
the way but it's like i don't want to be a bad
vampire they'll end the movie okay that's pretty
much the film and then they do this they cut to
now both of the post crisis they play between
credits so i think they're technically mid
credit scenes but who's who really says maker you
guys want to be like technical semantic [ __ ] in
the comments people call them post credits
it cuts to the first post credit scene it
immediately turns into what i can only describe as
a sizzle reel for the vulture spin-off movie like
obviously they're not going to make this vulture
spin-off movie because they they did it all here
in 30 seconds or less the first thing you see
the breaking in the sky like oh my god that's the
doctor strange spell no no way home that's what's
happening right now and then you see adrian tombs
michael keaton vulture transported into a
cell which raised some questions already of
okay i thought the spell was supposed to send
people home even that even though it's raising
questions like okay questions are fine i can
roll with it let's see what they do and then
they just screw it all up in like 10 seconds
the second freaking michael keaton gets there
hope the food's better in this joint it's like
what that was my first time like a comic book
guy of course he's unfazed and it's just like
all right i'll adjust i guess i gotta use this
multiverse thing to my advantage just to just
he doesn't know what's going on but sure well
just i got this under control i got records of my
existence here i'll just get out of jail and go do
stuff somehow felt very out of character to me it
didn't flow right it didn't seem right no element
of surprise it seemed like they didn't tell
michael keaton what was going on we can't tell
him because it might ruin it just act a little
bit like just say this line it felt that way
to me adrian toombs man who did everything
for his family and he's being transported to
nowhere in some like magical way yeah you'd
think he'd be a little freaked out even the
spider people were a little freaked out like how
did i get here what's going on but adrian toombs
hope food's better in this joint you know i built
a suit once out of alien technology i got this
and then it cuts to the news report footage right
what did i say on the news yeah they say something
about like oh adrian tombs he claims he just
showed up here there's a high chance he's going
to be led out of jail basically i'm paraphrasing
yeah that he'll be released right away because we
don't know who he is yeah and we're not gonna look
into that and it apparently just ends right there
that's scene one like what a stupid ass thing and
then it just started making me ask more questions
of what was the original post-credits what was
the original inclusion it's like so obvious that
when he's transferred to the prison that's a
reshoot they inserted because this had to come
out after no way home now it legit feels like
there was a plot line in the movie probably in
the scene where he was locked up and in the
orange jumpsuit where he probably would have
run into or met adrian tombs there that they then
took out of the movie and then went what's like
one or two of the most important bullet
points from that to get the point across
let's make that the post-credits scene
and then the second post-credits scene
they outdid themselves i already thought the first
one was bad enough oh no cut to morbius driving on
the highway where is he going where is he when i
thought he could fly now i thought he flies he's
saving his energy for christ he gets called two in
the morning apparently he's like flying under the
radar now why would you be speeding so fast in
a car then wouldn't you want to be flying what
he's got echolocation to sense cops you know so
apparently he feels like he's got some type of
threatening like there's a threat coming then
vulture comes flying in he's got a suit now no
one knows why or how you're out no one knows
how impressive i am michael morbius he shows
up and then it just had me go what message did he
send morbius initially to compel him to drive out
at near three in the morning when he shows up
and he's like this is a this is a threatening
situation not a good one what message did he
send him i feel like it would be way easier
to get michael morbius on board with you if
you just contacted him as adrian tubes honestly
the biggest issue i had with this scene is it felt
out of character for both of them and it was so
apparent they did not have the actors in the same
scene at least it felt that way it felt like they
had some voice over recordings for michael keaton
they had him do and then they had jared leto do a
few reactionary takes and then they were like well
figured out an editing you just put it in editing
we'll figure it out then it looks like they
repurposed a car commercial and then did a couple
shot reverse shots of jared leto in a field and
then made that the seat so the first thing that
michael keaton says is like thanks for meeting
with me doc it's like this is not what is this
what is the toner is your familial banter here
thanks for being moved doc yeah what is this
he seemed like he like called the meeting at like
three in the morning and it just seemed like such
a hey how's it going sorry to call you here under
such weird circumstances can't be too careful
and then he says i don't know how i got here
i think it has something to do with spiderman
it's just like such a bad dialogue then it just
further drove home that point it further drove
home like why is he just adjusting to here
and not trying to figure out how to get home
to his wife and kid like why is he not
trying to figure any of this out and again
why would vulture want to set up a sinister
six instead of trying to figure out how to get
back home like what's the motive here exactly
and then to make things more confusing he goes
on to say i'm thinking that you and i and a couple
other people like us we could put together a team
do some good do some good and then morbius is
just like intriguing i'm gonna do this and i'm
like wait wait there's a whole character turn
in here and a whole bunch of other mumbo jumbo
that we have no context for for either of them
in this situation and it's just more confusing
because is it like real good or sarcastic good
yeah like do some good like oh we can make good
money do like criminal yeah activities or is
are they going to try to make the sinister six
like a team of good there's a dirty dozen thirty
half dozen now why why would morbius be in the
only way i can see morbius being intrigued
is if he sincerely meant let's do some good
because that's who orbeez's character is in this
movie he would rather do some good but if it is a
setup for the sinister six to do some bad i'm like
why would he be intrigued what's intriguing about
what he's heard so far why is the question not
what do you mean what kind of good are you talking
about because you just presented me a display
of power rather than a display of intention
evelyn's you know that shouldn't end intriguing
so you should end on what are you talking about
and how is venom gonna figure into that too
because you know he's going to be part of that
team and venom is a character already established
to want to do a little good actual good whereas
like the vulture that doesn't seem like the mo
yet at all they've questioned the rules of the
spell which is something i think they can explain
away a little bit better that seems like it's a
combination of a bunch of deleted things it didn't
feel real like it does feel like it was made
a couple days ago it really does it felt like a
marketing team put together something last minute
let's make some readjustments let's let's let's
do it like this so what are some discarded takes
we can use let's just figure something out based
on that it seemed like they didn't tell geraldo
any direction and they were like just do
it a few times we'll see which one's best
for this and same thing with michael keaton like
it really got the sense that michael kitten didn't
even know what he was talking about the whole
setup is just confusing goes against character
for both of them in so many ways i thought
they were poorly put together poorly executed
confusing funny for all the wrong reasons and
uh they feel like a weird micro movie and they
make the previous whole movie you just saw feel
worse for having yes is i think part of it too
give it up sony keep it up really excited for
whatever six movie turns out to be i thought
that is so much worse of a sinister six setup and
the director confirms what he's doing that is so
much worse of a sinister six setup than what the
amazing spider-man 2 did yeah like that was like
oh god brother when that happened but at least
in some way they established that there's shady
things they're building here at oscar yeah here
this just just comes out of nowhere yes nowhere
so bad and it all harkens toward a sinister
six that's actually just a team of is just
the suicide squad or something a team of
anti-heroes who ultimately are not gonna
be allowed to be that sinister anyway
guys leave your thoughts down below
do you love it